et à retrouver le chemin jusqu'à leur nid
et à leurs terrains de chasse.
Il y avait des biologistes conservationnistes,
très renommés comme Stanley Temple,
qui est l'un des fondateurs de la biologie de la conservation,
et Kate Jones de l'IUCN, qui s'occupe de la Liste Rouge.
Ils sont enthousiastes à ce sujet,
mais ils soulèvent aussi le fait que ça puisse entrer en compétition
avec les efforts très importants pour protéger
les espèces menacées qui sont encore en vie,
qui ne se sont pas encore éteintes.
Vous voyez, il faut travailler à protéger les animaux dans la nature.
Il faut travailler à réduire le marché de l'ivoire en Asie
pour qu'il ne tue plus 25 000 éléphants par an.
Mais en même temps, les biologistes de la conservation se rendent compte
que les mauvaises nouvelles dépriment les gens.
Et donc la Liste Rouge est vraiment importante, pour tenir une liste
de ce qui est menacé ou gravement menacé, etc.
Mais ils sont sur le point de créer ce qu'ils appellent une Liste Verte,
et la Liste Verte recensera les espèces qui se portent bien, merci,
des espèces qui étaient menacées, comme l'aigle à tête blanche,
mais qui se portent bien mieux maintenant, grâce au bon travail de tout le monde,
et à des aires protégées partout dans le monde
qui sont très, très bien gérées.
Donc en gros, ils apprennent comment capitaliser sur des bonnes nouvelles.
Et ils voient le fait de faire revenir à la vie des espèces éteintes
comme le genre de bonnes nouvelles sur lesquelles on peut capitaliser.
Voici quelques exemples.
L'élevage en captivité sera une partie importante de l'effort pour ramener ces espèces.
Il ne restait plus que 22 condors de Californie en 1987.
Tout le monde pensait que c'en était fini pour lui.
Grâce à l'élevage en captivité au zoo de San Diego,
On en compte maintenant 405, dont 226 dans la nature.
Cette technologie va être utilisée sur les animaux dé-éteints.
Une autre réussite, c'est le gorille des montagnes en Afrique Centrale.
En 1981, Dian Fossey était sûre qu'ils allaient disparaître.
Il en restait tout juste 254.
Maintenant on en a 880. Leur population augmente
de 3% chaque année.
Le secret, c'est un programme d'éco-tourisme
absolument génial.
Cette photo a été prise le mois dernier par Ryan
avec un iPhone.
Juste pour vous montrer à quel point ces gorilles sont à l'aise avec les visiteurs.
Un autre projet intéressant, bien qu'il ait encore besoin d'aide,
concerne le rhinocéros blanc du nord
Il n'y a plus de couple en mesure de se reproduire.
Mais c'est pour ce genre de choses
qu'une grande variété d'ADN de cet animal est disponible au zoo cryogénisé.
Un peu de clonage et on peut les ramener.
Donc où va-t-on maintenant ?
Ces conférences étaient privées jusqu'à présent.
Je crois qu'il est temps de rendre le sujet public.
Qu'en pensent les gens ?
Est-ce que vous voulez ramener des espèces éteintes ?
(Applaudissements)
La fée clochette va apparaître.
C'est le moment de la fée clochette,
parce que, qu'est ce qui fascine les gens dans tout ça ?
Qu'est-ce qui les inquiète ?
Nous allons aussi continuer sur la tourte voyageuse.
Et Ben Novak, au moment même où je vous parle, a rejoint le groupe
que Beth Shapiro a formé à l'US Santa Cruz.
Ils vont travailler sur les génomes
de la tourte voyageuse et du pigeon à queue barrée.
A mesure que les données sont rassemblées, ils les enverront à George Church,
qui fera son tour de magie, et extraira l'ADN de la tourte voyageuse de tout ça.
Nous aurons l'aide de Bob Lanza et Mike McGrew
pour le transformer en plasma germinale qui peut être implanté dans des poulets
qui pourront produire des petites tourtes voyageuses
qui pourront être élevées par leurs parents pigeons à queue barrée
et à partir de là, ce seront des tourtes voyageuses jusqu'à la fin,
peut-être pour les six prochains millions d'années.
On peut faire la même chose, puisque les coûts baissent,
pour la perruche de Caroline, pour le grand pingouin
pour le tétras des prairies, pour le pic à bec ivoire,
pour le courlis esquimau, pour le phoque moine des Caraïbes,
pour le mammouth laineux.
Parce que la vérité, c'est que les humains ont fait un trou énorme
dans la nature, ces 10 000 dernières années.
Nous avons maintenant la possibilité,
et peut-être le devoir moral, de réparer une partie de ces dégâts.
La majeure partie de cela, nous le ferons en étendant et en protégeant les espaces naturels,
en étendant et en protégeant
les populations d'espèces en voie de disparition.
Mais certaines espèces
que nous avons complètement exterminées,
nous pourrions simplement les ramener
à un monde qui les regrette.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Merci.
J'ai une question.
C'est un sujet émouvant. Certains se sont levés.
Je soupçonne qu'il y en a certains assis ici,
qui se posent des questions du style,
stop, stop, stop, attendez une minute,
Il y a quelque chose de malsain à ce que l'homme
interfère de cette façon dans les processus naturels.
Il y aura des conséquences imprévues.
Vous allez ouvrir une sorte de boîte de Pandore
contenant Dieu sait quoi. Est-ce qu'ils ont raison ?
Stewart Brand : L'argument évoqué plus tôt, c'est que
nous avons déjà interféré massivement en faisant disparaître ces animaux,
et beaucoup d'entre eux étaient cruciaux,
et nous avons entièrement changé l'écosystème dans lequel ils existaient
en les laissant disparaître.
Maintenant, on peut avoir un problème de changement de référence, c'est-à-dire,
quand ces animaux reviendront,
ils pourraient remplacer d'autres oiseaux qui sont là
et que les gens connaissent et aiment beaucoup.
Je crois que ce sera en partie comme ça que ça fonctionnera.
C'est un long et lent processus --
Ce que j'aime là-dedans, c'est que c'est multi-générationel.
Nous allons ramener le mammouth laineux.
CA : Et bien, il semblerait que, à la fois, la conversation
et le potentiel de tout ça, soient très excitants.
Merci beaucoup pour votre présentation. SB : Merci.
CA : Merci. (Applaudissements)